sur la planète variété trenet a toujours
été un gars qui que je n'ai ni vers le
seuil de 10 est passé
1942 il est déjà fidèle à sa légende
monsieur roy 7 rue du vieux colombier
paris marchands de coco et sodas virgule
jardin du luxembourg actuellement
travail points toujours désiré connaître
petit métier c'est josiane bon parfait
s'est tenu pour son anniversaire mardi à
l'opéra bastille il a continué à nous la
jouer à la soirée notons les trouvailles
les audaces lumineux quand je serai
grand je voudrais revenir un autre
c'est le cas de monsieur klein qui fait
reine était proposé avec fringants qu'en
20 ans il fait pas son âge disait un
spectateur un peu innocent cpie du parc
c'était ben harper dit que je ne
l'espérais
il ya une communion magnifique avec son
public était un public comme j'aime
et comment m un patrimoine de l'huile
chansons beaucoup donné deux clowns
trenet est entraînée pour encore nous
étonner
un homme heureux c'est le coup du swing
sa console